this is
Valerie she was 5 years old when she
received
[Music]
chemotherapy
Valerie would receive chemotherapy
treatments here at the Clinica medical
Duarte in the small Border City of kuta
in
Columbia on January 23rd 2020 doctors at
the clinic gave Valerie a dose of
Methotrexate a drug used to treat
cancer less than 24 hours later she was
back in the hospital days later she was
dead the drug Valerie was given methat
trexate was made by napod Life Sciences
a manufacture headquartered in India a
country that supplies 20% of the world's
generic drugs but instead of being
sterile the medicine was contaminated
with bacteria and had become
dangerous in a month-long investigation
we learned this wasn't an isolated
incident nap's medicines have been
linked to dire quality issues with
almost zero
consequences this is a story of a drug
maker with a dangerous track record and
how it keeps selling medicine leaving
families and doctors to suffer the
[Music]
consequences Methotrexate is a drug used
to treat leukemia and other Cancers and
has been around for
decades when given as an injection the
conditions in which the drug is made are
always supposed to be sterile if the
wrong ingredients aren't tested
adequately if a production line isn't
cleaned properly if the water isn't
filtered thoroughly the life-saving
medicine could become potentially
lethal Napo Life Sciences plays a
crucial if sometimes unnoticed role in
the world's drug supply
chain none of its medicines are for sale
in the US instead it mostly sells
directly to suppliers in low-income
countries batches of the cancer drug
method trexate made here in 2018 and
2019 were sent to clinics in Colombia
later Colombian drug Regulators
confirmed that a dangerous bacteria was
found in the
drug doctors suspected more than a 100
patients had suffered reactions linked
to the contaminated medicine a total of
four kids died and the drug was later
recalled
my colleague Panka Pula looked into na
PR's operations in India this is a PL
that makes many lowcost cancer generics
for big brand names such as inas Dr
reedy's and aott former employees of nap
Rod whom we spoke to told us that the
quality control in this company was not
up to the mark and was neglected
greatly the former quality control
employee spoke to us in condition of
anonymity he was asked to hurry through
quality
test our seniors used to see us
sometimes just skip that part and
complete that
work what did you think when you heard
about this uh pseudomonas contamination
in Colombia uh coming from nap routs
products it is found in the seal well it
is definitely coming from the company it
is not coming from anywhere
else the damage can never be
it
is Indian Regulators have frequently
failed to detect and clam down on really
dangerous quality
[Music]
issues Maharashtra FDA is trying their
best to get a good quality medicine to
people around the world not only in
India though we don't have any
sufficient staff we are trying were
working very hard and they have
corrected their
problems they told that we already
rectified it was a minor problem in
Colombia they have asked and they have
already taken the action they have
investigated state governments are very
eager to attract the pharmaceutical
industry and to get them to set up their
manufacturing plants because it helps
them generate revenue and jobs and the
state Regulators are directly under the
state governments
these State Regulators are not very well
staffed they are underfunded if you put
these two things together it's a very
dangerous cocktail because this means
that India's huge manufacturing industry
doesn't get as much oversight as it
needs this wasn't the first time quality
issues were found at naon in India three
separate batches of its Cancer drugs
failed quality tests in 2017 and 2018 in
Ethiopia researchers tested multiple
samples of its chemo drug and found only
half the stated active ingredient yet
the company has not faced any serious
consequences from Regulators the big
pharmaceutical companies buying nao's
products or public health warnings from
the World Health Organization napro
declined to comment on Valerie's case or
other cases in Columbia setting ongoing
legal
proceedings the company said it has
responded appropriately to Quality
concerns raised by regulators and makes
high quality
[Music]
products
so who is to blame for Valerie's death
and how can people in low-income country
countries ensure their drugs are
safe despite its track record naod
continued selling medicines around the
world cashing in on growing markets for
generic Cancer
drugs and Valerie's case is stuck in the
Labyrinth of Colombian government
bureaucracy the Attorney General's
office received Valerie's autopsy report
four years ago it has listed her cause
of death is under
study in the years that have passed
there have been few signs of progress in
the probe in in recent months the
Attorney General's office has started
interviewing families and others
involved but 2,500 miles away a
researcher in the US is trying to
perfect a test to help detect bad
quality drugs before they reach
patients the market for chemotherapy
products is increasing and it's
increasing in locations where often the
regulatory agencies are underresourced
particularly for analysis of Highly
toxic chemotherapy products and so it's
a very risky situation right now the
paper test her team developed is a field
lab kit run on a sample of medicine
testing for the amount of active
ingredient it costs as little as $2 and
can be done easily by a nurse using a
cell phone and these are a field
screening device that you can use to
check a medicine quickly and see if it
looks good or if it looks
suspicious
nearly four years after Valerie's death
naod continues to sell its drugs to
customers around the
[Music]
world
oh